hello we're glad to join our service
live webinar
oh sure sensitive single molecule errors
technology to revolutionize DNS
biomarkers perceptions like water and
restroom and PhD chief medical officer
of contract Court
I am Marjorie Torres of lathers and I'll
be moderating the session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
libraries the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advanced and
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by lab routes to
learn more visit w-w-w a calm let's get
started you can serve questions to the
speakers during the presentation while
they're freshmen in line to do so simply
type into the Q&A box which will open
when you collect the excreting humanoid
button at the lower left of the
presentation window
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarges drive windows
click on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you experience technical problems being
or hearing the presentation just click
on the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or a
reporter problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at lower left this is
an educational webinar and thus offers
free continuing education credits after
the webinar is over please click on the
CD button located in the bottom
left-hand corner of the web page and
follow the process of obtaining your
credit I now present today's speakers
dr. Andrea Romans dr. Andrea Roman has
more than 25 years of experience in EMS
clinics diagnostic and companion
diagnostics and co-authors more than 150
publications he is the founder of
Atlantic biomarkers Inc and currently
the consulting chief medical officers
chief contracts Corp and members of
several biomarkers in EMS disorder
consortia and working group I will now
turn the presentation over to dr.
andreas derailments
thank you very much it's pleasure to
talk to you to you to you today and
welcome so the title of my presentation
is single molecule array technology to
revolutionize CNS biomarkers and as you
heard I'm the scientific and medical
adviser to quanta ryx corporation based
in Lexington Massachusetts so what I've
done in this slide deck is basically
give you an overview on the technology
which is the single molecule array
technology combined with a few case
application in the CNS biomarker space
in particular with regard to blood based
biomarkers so what you see on slide
number two is now our customers a
snapshot of our customer base this emile
similar technology has been has begun to
be commercialized in 2012 on terraces in
existing since 2007 it just celebrated
this 10 years anniversary as well and
this technology really has be is very
rapidly adopted as you see on this slide
as well so we have a number of key
academic partners Research Institute
listed on the left part of the slide a
number of biopharma companies with names
over may be very familiar with and a
number of contract research
organizations and other institutions who
have utilized and continue to utilize
this similar technology so as of today
there are about 150 instruments and
you'll see what I mean by instrument in
this phase and we have a very rapidly
developing menu of biomarker assays in
particular in the central nervous system
space so on this particular slide what
is kind of the opportunity in our
perspective for the similar technology
and I should say that in the first
application is an ultra sensitive
detection technology in particular for
proteins but it can also be used for the
detection of nucleic acids in other
forms of molecules as well
if one general just one has a capture
reagent and the detection reagent
available as
so in our is an hour of you and it
worthless field we can compare this to
what we call the iceberg analogy here
there's really just a small number of
they're approved or cleared test from a
regulatory perspective as in diagnostic
news but there's also a very small
number of peptides or proteins which are
detectable within the entire proteome of
about 220,000 independent open reading
frames as well and one of the
limitations or maybe the limitations in
the space is the lack of sentiment we
called sensitivity to detect these in
particular no abundance molecules as we
find them in in blood as they relate for
example some central nervous system
disorders this is shown here only in the
iceberg analogy that we really just see
the very tip of the iceberg with current
technologies and there's a great need to
improve in the sensitivity of our
current immunoassays to push the
detection limit down to what we call the
single molecule netherlands one on the
next slide is a representation of really
the seminal publication from 2011
published in Nature technology which
basically just sticks on the left-hand
side and the cartoon the principles
underlying the single molecule array or
what I call enjoyed some more technology
as well on the upfront side so the way
we detect a give an analyte down to the
single molecule this is a very
traditional sandwich Eliza so we're
capturing our analyte of interest with a
capture antibody which as you can see in
this slide here on the left is coupled
to a each and then we're detecting that
analyte with the detection antibody and
fluorescence is our quantification
signal V as well
unlike a very traditional trade based
Eliza so those people who are familiar
with the 96-well format of an Eliza
we don't detect these molecules within
the bulk solution of a micro well-played
but we now isolate these beads who have
captured down to a single molecules into
a single well and that's kind of
depicted in the cartoon here to the left
where you see this world as well is
designed from a size perspective that it
can just hold a single a single deed in
with in theory a single analyte as well
and by isolating now these captured
analytes on a building to a single world
we dramatically increase the
signal-to-noise ratio and detection
capabilities and sensitivity of a given
Eliza on the next slide you see this
again depicted in a different way so you
have your incoming matrix as we call it
to the analyse that could be blood could
be whole blood could be ETA plasma
plasma could be cherem as well this is
we take a sample out of this cube
typically 25 microliters incubate this
with our capture antibody couple 280
this is you what you secret tooth down
to the right and then basically come in
with the detection antibody and then we
iso made now these sandwiches who have
detected a single analyte now into the
single wheels into the single wells
which are actually arranged on a disk
which is typical blu-ray technology
technical technology which was adapted
now to build these he's what we these
discs as well we have 24 different
locations on the disk and they are the
beads are push now into these well into
these wells as well so you have empty
positions here the majority of empty if
you have no concentration then you have
single wells which is filled with a
single bead and if you see to the far
down right now these single wells which
capture to have are filled by a single
bead are lighting up if they could if
they actually contain an analyte of
interest or multiple analytes of
interest so don't let the very low
concentration and now we're typically in
that we are typically in what we call
the digital mode as well so we typically
actually count the number of beads who
either have their signal we call them on
signals or those which we don't and we
actually for narration that's our
quantitative we don't secondly call it
average enzyme cookies
and here is a comparison to the typical
traditional 96-well eliza format which
is drawn on the top so this is what we
call the analog mode because as I said
you detect your molecules in bulk
typical reaction volume is your hundred
microliters so a hundred times 10 to the
minus six liters as well and you are
limited really by diffusion in this
hundred micro liter of volume within a
given well this is in contrast to the
similar technology which is as I said in
the digital mode at the low
concentration range of molecules as well
so here now you have a reaction volume
of 50 times to the my 10 to the minus 15
because that's the volume of a single
well which we are going to hold the
single bead it's 50 femtometers so now
in comparison to the 10 to the minus 6
times in the minus 15 you have a 10
billion times smaller reaction volume
and increase in sensitivity or signal or
noise as well so for this technology one
molecule is needed to reach the
detection limit II as well obviously if
you have more and more molecules now
being bound to these beads and things
filter is micro lace here as well the
ways of single wells
you know transition into the analog mode
so you have ditch there you have ultra
sensitivity individual de mode the more
molecules you bind the transition into
the analog mode as well and this gives
you a dynamic range of about 4 to 5
lakhs as you see in a traditional Alijah
this technology can also be multiplexed
as well which is depicted on this
particular slide and the way we
multiplex the similar technology is
basically encoding another color onto
these beads so now in addition to your
fluorescence signal you take as a
quantitative readout you have another
color let's say yellow red or blue or
green as you see here as well and
depending on the color of the beads this
now encodes the analyte you like to
catch a capture so multiplexing means
you can detect and quantify multiple
analytes within a given sample ie it's
multiplexing and
like basically encoding another color on
the base now we have another color which
is encoded or encodes your analyte of
interest to be detected which is
determined by the capture and detect
specificity of the capture and detection
antibody coated onto these feeds so you
not only have ultra sensitivity for the
similar technology
you also have capabilities of
multiplexing as well and you have the
capability of actually developing your
own essay as well if you either if you
have access or have already developed
the sandwich eliezer because this is
what we call an open platform so
quantity rick does provide a solution
for custom essay development either done
in-house by quanta X or done by our
customers who have adopted the
technology as what we call this a custom
se development solution homebrew so you
have provided you as a customer or
potential customer provided with the
beads to conjugate your capture antibody
or reagent and then with the chemistry
to biotin innate your detection antibody
to be in this similar essay format as
well on this particular table you see a
comparison to some of the traditionally
known elijah's or developed their lives
as commercial and diagnostic rate in
nature I just want to point out a few so
you see here Tao and we'll talk about
the microtubule associated protein tau
in a few minutes as well we have
typically sensitivity in what we call
the pentagram per millimeter range and
that compares to for example a currently
used research used only in diagnostic
assay developed by a no tester 4G reveal
in aid 3500 for increase in sensitivity
as well
another example is an essay for the HIV
capsid protein 324
similar this in morelo you see down here
is point zero zero two five pictograms
firmly de Givenchy conventional clinical
diagnostic assay developed by Auto
diagnostic is 15
grandpa leader and I should say that
this particular essay developed on some
more complete 24 actually utilizes the
same antibodies employed in the ortho
assay so it's a direct comparison as
well as you see on this particular slide
there is a 6000 fold increase of
sensitivity here as well if you look at
this particular number as well and this
actually makes this si now the 224 si
this is a detection of protein it's a
capsid protein as I said up of HIV
similar insensitivity to nucleic acid
technology such as such as PCR if the
technology is currently being offered is
it is standalone is up with the idea to
allow for the the instrument it fridges
the commune's to automated in
specialized bike want Eric's or your own
in-house developed si as I said through
the home go program or the homebrew si
and then 45 minutes and plus there
abouts the first results are provided
and we basically obtained results in
form of a spreadsheet so it's a very
traditional clinical chemistry analyzer
type of arrangement what you also see on
this slide is ie the kit components
we'll talk about in a second and then
the disc I refer to and these discs
contain all these 24 positions of these
arrays of the micro Wells we discussed a
few slides ago
so the typical workflow here on the left
is a deep step one that you'll know if
your consumer vaults either cadets the
kids and then the reaction is performed
in cadets you note the disc as I said
you select USA either this is an assay
you purchased from contrary to develop
your own you know your samples and then
in 45 minutes plus typically 75 minutes
your first results
they in step five this basically data
transfer and data analysis on a CNS
perspective we do have a number of key
partnerships in place to really provide
qualified VH neurosciences as well we're
working with the company in Virginia a
related biomarkers as well on diagnostic
we blow the neuron neurology pipeline
you'll see on this slide just to give
you a feel of the devil so it's really
what we call with car first in class so
we have various essays for biomarkers
and you don't I don't need to go through
all these mark oh I know I chain I will
show you this data we have developed
Parkinson's disease related biomarkers
such as alpha-synuclein as well taking
people d3 and BDNF which is important as
a biomarker and psychiatric disorders as
well importantly enough coming back to
this concept of multiplexing we have
begun out to commercialize markers for a
combination of variants of these markers
an essay to be released in April of 2017
is a market at remember we call
traumatic brain injury market a
four-plex
containing total tau G FAPE CHL one
that's a cell body injury marker as well
and or filament light chain as well and
as you see we also have begun to and
we'll make essays commercially available
for various synaptic posto so
presynaptic proteins as well in addition
we have a large mention for cytokine
markers as well and for various
cardiovascular and oncology markers as
well but the focus of today's
presentation is on CNS
Marcus I in the remainder of this
presentation are going to give you an
overview of some of these applicants
ecology space there is more than 50
publications now I this kind of what
with our bio mark pain into what we call
ourselves
that's not completely but what some of
these trans it does have not been really
basic is flowing from the from the
brains through the spinal fluid into the
blood they may be other clearance
mechanism in the brain some just to the
lymphatic system as well which will help
with the removal of let's call it toxic
proteins or waste proteins from the
brain into into the periphery as well
and the idea is that because of this
filter here the concentration of some of
these analytes are in blood by much
obviously much lower than in brain but
they are also much lower than its
release of spinal fluid and what the
similar technology the technology really
has enabled over the last few years is
not to move to going to year and advance
the frontier of CNS biomarkers from CSF
into blood and to show that this has
clinical useful applications as well and
some of the application out presented to
you in the coming slides
if a bit of a feel how much is there
actually I provide I wanted to draw this
analogy in here this is an excellent as
well here's a pizza about 5,500 picogram
per Mille there now here if you convert
this this relates to about 500
milligrams per thousand cubic metre of
office of a swimming pool Olympic sized
swimming for the size of 20 by 25 and 2
meters deep as well obviously in CSF and
blood we have a majority of other
proteins other than NFL particular
albumin which make up the majority of
protein which were not really in so much
interested in from a disease state
perspective so if we now convert here
the concentration in plasma the 50
milligram per milliliter
this makes about 50 tons per persuade
mning pool so to put this in a little
bit more illustrative environment as
well for plasma and plasma NFL the 10
people gram per millimeter as a object a
kind of would correspond to about one
three hundred of the sugars of a sugar
cube of NFL her an Olympic sized
swimming pool of 20 by 25 by tooling
distance so in other words it's a very
small amount of of sugar cube in this
particular pool and one obviously needs
a very sensitive and precise technical
technology such as the similar
technology in order to be able to detect
this very small amount of sugar cube or
analyte or biomarker of interest but in
the next slide I'll we'll discuss the
use of the detection of a
protein called as well which is a
protein which is mainly found in neurons
as well was in place an important role
ended the scientific evidence shows that
after external injury at the polymerizes
and aggregates in the type of
phosphorylated as well so over the last
few years there's really been a wealth
of data generated to show how complex of
a molecule town really is there's
evidence of extracellular secretion of
tau not just found intracellularly as
well and this making the toxic form of
tao's which leads to spread of town
between neurons and glia cells as well
but it's also become clear that tau is
heavily past what we call post
translational modification also by
activations like oscillations and other
forms of phosphorylation and aggregating
into oligomeric forms of tau and it is
also processed and cleaved by proteases
at the end and at the c-terminus as well
so it's a complex molecule Erick's has
developed an ultra-sensitive sa to total
tau and also not it is how but this data
here
pathology well it's over your critical
characteristic has a limit of detection
as per milliliter i was participating or
little attending this presentation were
familiar as well this meets all the
criteria of a physical purpose
validation for research use only si if
we look at this in terms of precision so
if we run this now on multiple days and
compare within a run on a day or between
runs over day you see that typically we
essays perform with a precision less
than
percent mm and now this is one exam a a
presentation if the data were published
in Italy this is now in sweet SS la idea
on the Left they take a comparison now
of past issues versus past season and as
if you listen to perceive this image is
to actually use in concussed players and
compare this to preseason so on the left
here you have preseason as well and then
you basically have a time course here
now on the on the right over a period of
144 hours so as early as 1 hour 12 hours
and 144 hours and what product if you
look at the mean values of M but how to
read you actually see that as early as
1:00 hours in the contrast players total
car was elevated compared compared
compared to preseason suggesting at
potential diagnostic views of total tau
in in these professional ice hockey
players as well the question then arose
can this also be used to gain the total
tower concentration of the kinetic
profile of total tau also be used to
inform what we call return to play so
when is it safe for a player to return
to play without any potential long-term
consequences of this traumatic brain
injury I'd now you see a a study out of
this
publication work basically we have here
again oops now so that was with L forms
of injury more models here forms of
injury based yeah what's it like and
then read here you have what they call
type three in this publication is the
form of art and compared to the mild and
moderate here you have a more sustained
and significant increase now in total
tau over time before it returns to
baseline as well and this is also the
Claire were based on the severity of the
TBI or concussion it took the longest
time to return to play so there is the
first suggestion of data here that total
tau in in blood this is not measured in
CSF this is measured in blood can be
used when followed longitudinally as a
potential measure to inform return to
play and this is something we have
independently now confirm in a very
recent 2016 neurology publication in
collegial acnes not in professional ice
hockey players as well so summary for
this particular slide is that plasma how
may serve as additional tool to enable
return to play other markers biomarkers
of potential brain injury of potential
biomarkers of brain injury analyzed in
this publication such as a calcium
binding protein known as s 100 feeder
and neuron specific analyzed and unlike
tau s 100 feeder in Tennessee did not
seem to correlate to return to play time
or decisions here as well switching now
from photo tau to another external
protein this is a in s1 or filament like
clay of North column in each chain on
the top here North Pole in the medium
chain that north end of it like vary by
molecular weight as you see in this
slide as well you have developed now and
say an ultra-sensitive blood can also be
used this slide here now you see a
comparison before I discussed it or that
you actually saw it comparing what is
plotted in this slide here is either a
signal in the eliza in comparison to a
to this Amenti bodies employed in this
mo the SI actually was originally did as
one and then both the Elijah Sigma and
the similar sa signal are plotted
against increasing concentration of your
filament light shade and as you increase
the concentration of northern and light
chain as walking cause your calibrator
obviously the signal in your in your a/c
would would go up and this is typically
what we see a calibration curve here so
if you see in this slide that the SI is
basically the curve ends here this is
where around here where is where the
limit as well where you basically have
an increase to report you and a standard
deviation is over blank in here is
depicted actually where the clinical
samples typically read so with your
Eliza you actually limit is therefore
higher concentration able to detect NFL
in ignore Phil and his life chain and
blood but the same antibodies were now
employed deployed on the Samoa assay
which is shown here in the blue triangle
and the blue triangles here and you see
that you now extend the assay who was
what we call the lower end of the curve
as well and now you're venturing out
into being able to quantify your
filament light chain in blood in the
squeezed window here as well so again
coming back to the theme of this
presentation you have now ventured and
you
I shouldn't push the frontier from being
a CSF honestly only in being able to
precisely quantified nor a filament
light chain and blood and I'll show you
in the remainder of this presentation
some of the clinical application one is
the correlation between NFL in CSF and
and blood and of some of the clinicals
this here comes black to the discus area
of clearance of some of these the NFL
versus in an excellent blood versus here
up about point nine seven which is
obviously highly statistically
significant as well so good correlation
between what your excellent correlation
what you measure in CSF compared what
you measure in some of the applications
here now and so this is a pump by
Jonathan Laurel now in entry as well our
controls versus various forms of a
frontal various behavior variance as we
call them including a form of
unbusinesslike phenotype are and what
you see here that all these are the
concentration of north element light
chain is measured in serum now as well
compared to the controls are elevated as
well and you start seeing a
differentiation of the Ursuline the
night chain levels between these various
this different variants of
frontotemporal dementia in particular
frontal temporal dementia with a motor
neuron disease phenotype FL in CSF
originally was also used to different
the diagnosis of in this order so
differentiate Parkinson's disease from
this disease mark is one of these exact
on this is a clinical diagnostic
relevant and what you see here is now
your filament light chain levels now
compared in controls in typical forms of
Parkinson's disease including people as
well but then a table because I typical
forms of Parkinson's as I mentioned
before including MSA and as you see here
all controls versus all other groups the
normal and the nitrate concentrations
here are different they are elevated
compared to the control and also PSP so
super super Knox nuclear palsy MSA and
CPD is different from all other groups
so here now is again an example where
previously in CSF only detected nora
filament light chain can be used in
blood which is up way more accessible
matrix compared to CSF
which is to be generated by a lumbar
puncture can be used for the
differential diagnosis of a typical
Parkinson's disorders versus Parkinson's
disorders and this is will be
implemented in the in the clinic in the
not-too-distant future as an example
coming out of the Alzheimer's space here
now is while looking at al in the
correlation to various cognitive
pitching changes this is a little bit of
busy slide but we just focused to this
is a change of neural filament light
pink patients over time as a function
known as the minimus exam as well in
this now the neural filament
concentration these different colors
were entered into different portals as
well to basically group Alzheimer's
disease with the highest concentration
of neural filament light chain from from
control
and my forms of cognitive informant and
pmn what we call MCI so in below here
would be the VAD group as well of the
highest quartile in what you see here
that there's a nice :
good correlation between the neural
filament life chain concentration T as
well in this various quartile as a
function of cognitive performance II as
well as is also replicated on the right
here with a different measure of
cognition as well so here we're
measuring noir film and life chain or
originally found in axons now being
released honorable generation in the CSF
and blood we actually do show that this
is a important indicator and correlates
to changes in declines in cognitive
performance and also the correlates
since on the psyche as well to various
measures of your imaging as well so
we're mirroring in the correct way we're
measuring no concentration of nor
filament light shade and this is
indicative of brain pathology and
clinical changes in participants in
subjects at work obviously this has
significant implication not just in
understanding this neural degenerative
diseases but also with regard to the use
of normal filament in extremely drug
development as well so with this I want
to finish today's present it was a bit
of a an clinical application I three
hopefully eyes a lot a biomarker as
related proteins as well for diagnose
and I'll be getting really calm in chat
as well you see my email address at the
bottom of the you know please feel free
to reach out for additional questions of
mutations or or any any other
monix in business I thank you for your
attention
thank you doctor you're chairman for
your presentation a quick reminder for
our audience on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box found by
clicking on the Korean human eye button
at the lower left of the presentations
in this dr. Andreea Stroman will answer
as many questions of time for this the
first question is for which biomarkers
do you see the greatest need in terms of
sensitivity thank you so as I gave you a
few examples here the idea really is
more I think in sectionally that we as a
field we're coming to the realization
that like an oncology these brain
diseases are really molecular defined
diseases so we need coming back to the
toolbox idea multiple biomarkers to
really understand the pathophysiology
not just for diagnostic applications but
also for the efficient for efficiency
measurements of drug development
efficiency and safety measurements as
well so this idea of precision medicine
as well to target specific drugs to
specific patient populations either in
the Alzheimer's space in the Parkinson
disease traumatic brain injury and other
other CNS disorders as well some of the
biomarkers I think I talked about this
today we didn't talk much about the a
video peptides as well whereas aids are
available as well we talked about total
tall nor thin and light chain and I
think in the category of markers again
we didn't have the time to talk about
today our pre and postsynaptic markers
potentially as very early markers of
disease processes as well one of the
things and I think this is another
question of yours is really to diagnose
these diseases early when there is the
highest probability of therapeutic
success
follow the blood which which are other
fools searches to Lila you think are
important for the detection of
biomarkers for rich applications
diagnosis and clinical trials so
compared to CSF rotational blood and
that there are various other so compared
to CSF they are the generate of the
collection of blood is less is less
invasive and there are technologies
being developed to make it in less
invasive than what we traditionally have
known as the botany in this space but I
think venturing out in into fluids which
can be generated more in a home type of
setting such as saliva is an important
venue of research for the future so it's
the collection of potentially tears if
we think about this from an
ophthalmology perspective looking in in
other matrices in the more and the
periphery I think such as urine is worth
really the similar technology is
truth-seeking position because of the
low abundance of some of these
biomarkers
looks like we have time for one more
question which are the most important
preclinical or clinical applications
cheese
so again one of the areas of application
we didn't really talk about today as we
have the use of the similar technology
in preclinical ie animal models for
example where the cerebral spinal fluid
is very limited from a volume
perspective so there are several
applications now were a similar
technology because of its address
density B has been used to allow the
detection of multiple biomarkers in CSF
in animal model for example of neural
degeneration and the added benefit a
larger sensitivity is is the fact that
we can actually dilute of the semblance
to be able to quantify the analyte and
then the combined this was multiplexing
this is a win-win situation from a
clinical perspective coming back to this
idea of precision medicine in really
diagnosing brain disease the greenish
earlier to reduce some of what we call
the diagnostic delay but also to be able
to really treat patients much earlier in
the disease projectory I think is the
future of precision medicine in CNS
disorders
I would like to once again thank dr.
Andres chairman for his presentation do
you have any final comments hopefully
this was informative to the audience as
well I look forward to future
discussions and as I said before please
feel free to reach out to me well the
were lab roads for for additional
questions I'd like to thank the audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed by this speaker via the
contact information he has provided time
of registration we would like to thank
lab information today's educational lab
trespass possible this podcast can be
viewed on-demand through July 13 2017
Labyrinth will alert you via email is
available to lu5 we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye